and violence against women and girls
happens because women are consistently
and constantly presented as second-class
citizens and up for grabs as a
politician for women's equality this I
think more than anything has really
shocked me to see up closer the other
political parties tackle this because
violence against women is cause and
consequence of women's inequality and it
is an epidemic one in four women
experience domestic violence two women a
week are killed by their partner or
their former partner eleven reaps an
hour are reported and those are just the
ones that are reported and as we know
the vast majority are not reported
because women are told that they are
lying or that they brought it on
themselves the rates of violence against
women in this country speak volumes
about women's inequality and yet when
you talk to people from other political
parties about this they seek to manage
it they talk about police they don't
talk about ending it they talk about it
as though it is something that we will
always have to live with so let's talk
about police numbers the way we end
violence against women and girls is to
build a tolerant and a respectful
society which we do by all of the things
that I have been talking about we teach
equality and education we share care we
pay equally on an understanding that we
have equal worth we see decisions in
business and politics taken equally by
men and by women we build a media that
relies for success on reflections of
diversity and fairness that creates
output in which women's lives and
experiences and needs are depicted
equally and honestly we build new tech
platforms on which women can debate and
exchange ideas without being hounded
into silence we end violence against
women and girls by building equal
democracies equal judiciary's by telling
men no you may not rape and take and
kill with impunity
we put you
Human Rights at the top of everyone's
agenda
you